during covid policy makers tried to
convince us that distance education was
a good substitute for classroom learning
like here when Gavin Newsom said it
would be equivalent to in-person classes
so this isn't true coveted school
closures were a disaster and we keep
getting new evidence showing how bad it
really was this latest study found that
the more time kids spent in online
school the worse they did on
standardized tests the study looked at
State testing data for third through
eighth graders before and after the
pandemic Pass rates for students in
classrooms were 13 points higher in math
and seven points higher in English
compared to kids who were fully online
similarly the latest scores on the
national assessment for educational
progress tests showed the loss of two
decades of progress in reading and math
ACT test scores saw a similar drop
dipping to their lowest point in three
decades in 2021 so the evidence is clear
closing schools was a terrible idea that
left a generation of kids falling behind